[Music]  what's your guilty pleasure when it  comes to eating stuff yeah james when  you sat in your favorite film or tv show  is on what and you think i shouldn't be  eating i'm eating this guilt-free it's a  friday night i've been to the gym i'm  gonna eat it what is it  a burrito  what's inside it's just like there's  this place called tapatio that is near  my house  and they have the best burritos like the  carnitas is so amazing  like the hot sauce i don't even know  it's like 3 000 calories for the burrito  so i'm always like trying not to get the  burrito and then like about once every  10 days i'm like screwed like last night  i was like i can't stand it i've got to  have the breathing well you look like a  man that's very much in shape you don't  have the burrito every day right  i'm always trying not to have the  burrito  harmonize with me and hold me tight all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your boy's the baby you're my pearl  [Music]